12月の24日日曜日
23時40分！！！！みなさぁん
(-_-)
メリークリスマァス！！！！！
ヒョォォォ↑↑
今日はなんとクリスマスイブ・そしてぇっ
もうしばらくすると　クリスマスになります。そこでですね
までのこの6時間のことを、
言われているわけでございますよ
なったんだと思うんですけどぉ
・・・
フザケンジャネェゾマジデ　　そういう日なんで
逆に、
逆にもう今日みたいな
めっちゃ雨ふってますけどぉ、めちゃくちゃザマァってかんじなんですけどぉ
滅茶苦茶雨降ってるなかの、12月24日の
性の６時間のど真ん中です 今 性の6時間のど真ん中のなかでぇ、
今から公園で1時間だけオフ
会を開きますこのクリスマスのど真ん中に
オフ会開くと
何人来てくれるのか、検証していこうとおもいます。
来る？来ないでしょいや結構
中々来ないと思うんで、
予想だけちょっと立ててみますか。何人ぐらいだと思う？
リアルに？リアルに。３０人！？
俺は、信じるよみんなを
攻めるねぇいやみんなピ～してる時に
どうやって戦いとか
もう早速つぶやいちゃいましょう場所はもう決まっててこっから
すぐいけるんで
というわけで乱れに乱れたこのクリスマス真っ只中かつ、この
天気の悪いなかで何人の方が
オフ会
に来てくれるのか検証していきたいとおもいます
ではいこう
雨ザァ～～～
プレゼント買いすぎた【汗】はいというわけで
オフ会会場に到着しました！
ここですね
ここでオフ会開くんですけど、まだ誰も
来てませんが、
こっから1時間待ちます
もう来たか、散歩の人か
そうだよね(*´Д｀)
やべっ後2分でクリスマスイブが終わる【泣】俺たち２人で公園の
ど真ん中にいる
えっと今ＲＴが１０００超えました
ただ、みんな なんか文句言ってますｗ
静岡はずるいぞーのぶ子は家で🍰作ってる雨ふってるから気をつけてね
ありがとうございます
やっぱあれだね静岡限定なのがまた難しさのポイントで
初のオフ会0人くるかこれわ！！
実際あしたぐらいにまとめサイトに
悲しい音楽と悲しい雨の音
歴史に残るで
残るねぇ～
12月25日でございます
残り、、、オフ会時間が４５分になりました
人の声聞こえた
人の声した
したしたしたしたしたした
パリピぜいかもしんない
は:静大？
人:静大です
え、オフ会に来てくれたんですか？
そ～で～す
いえ～～～～い⇈（テンションMAX）
ガヤガヤワイワイ
皆さんクリスマスプレゼントです
は:クリスマスプレゼントです
は:7人きてくれました、ありがとうございます
は :え、マジで０人かと思ってた
皆:いやいやいや
は :8人目が来てくれました！
え？凄いよ？
え、凄いねぇ～
人数数えてみよう
もうちょっと粘ってみましょ
しゅ～りょ～～～～
皆さん終了です〜
お疲れ様でした〜
8888888パチパチパチ
では、集計していこうと思います
すげ～